last week a watchdog group came out and
wanted fast food restaurants to stop
giving away toys in their meals because
they said it promoted childhood obesity
now they want McDonald's to whack Ronald
McDonald corporate accountability says a
recent poll shows 47% of people think it
is time for Ronald to retire corporate
accountability International is calling
on Ronald to retire even though he's a
lot skinnier than he used to
be it seemed like everyone was coming
for Ronald's head that is coming for his
head as a figure of speech until until
2011 when a finnished food activist
group kidnapped him over complaints
about the ingredients used in McDonald's
food and then they made their demands
now this is in Finish we love burgers
fries and McDonald's but we can no
longer Watch Silent when the food we
love is being destroyed when McDonald's
refused to respond the food activist
released a second video of a Ronald
statue being beheaded by a guillotine